Ted Cruz went on a complete manic tear
yesterday during a senate hearing with
the United States Secretary of Homeland
Security
Alejandro mallorcas this is Ted Cruz
auditioning for Fox News when Ted Cruz
wants to get himself on Fox News either
interviewed or have his Clips played he
does these sort of manic scream fests
with oversized poster boards behind him
and he certainly pulled out all the
stops yesterday take a look at this and
five hundred thousand five hundred
thousand it drops to the lowest level
and boom what happens you show up and
that red line is you now let's talk
about that couple different things here
this this they love this they love to
say the number of encounters with border
patrol went up when Joe Biden became the
president now there are two really
important things to understand about
that number one mobility in general was
really really low during the pandemic
and in fact you can see that on the
chart that Ted Cruz has behind him what
we started to see was as the pandemic
eased and the weather improved a huge
backlog of people who would have tried
to cross previously tried to cross the
border but here's the most important
thing
when encounters show up on this chart
it's because the people were stopped the
people were stopped it if you are going
to argue that the borders are open and
people are just going through you can't
defend that by saying look at all these
people stopped by border patrol by
definition that's because the Border
isn't open
to happen let me ask you we now have
over 5.5 million people who've entered
this country illegally under Joe Biden
how many murderers Have You released
into America
let me say something if you you know if
you take a look at no and this is Ted
Cruz not actually wanting to get answers
about anything this is a performance
piece and a pretty bad one at that no
you don't get to give a speech do you
know how many murders I'm just trying to
answer your question how many rapists
Have You released Senator I'm trying you
know your question you can answer I know
or I don't know Senator any individual
who poses a public safety threat how
many child molesters Have You released
and removed into the United States from
the United States and this word of
releasing is straight out of the Trump
Playbook Trump has been insisting quote
mental institutions are being emptied
out and released into the United States
of course that's not happening this is a
tryout this is a performance so your
testimony
jury
editors rapist or child molesters
um Mr chairman may I have the
opportunity no you may not you may
answer my question
you're you're not is that your testimony
yes or no Senator you're not allowing me
to answer your I am allowing you to
answer I'm not allowing you to follow if
you take a look at the the pace of
immigration in 2018 to 2019. you're
refusing to answer let's move on let's
move on to God always yeah
um this is not how you learn anything
this is not how you fix anything this is
not this is really nothing this is no
it's not of any value here's more of it
if Ted Cruz just losing his mind these
are modern day leg irons because these
are children being sold into sex slavery
and you don't even know what they are
that is astonishing Mr secretary how
many children have been sold into sex
slavery under your Administration
Senator we are taking it to the cartel
how many children have been sold into
sex slavery do you know how many
children I mean how many were sold under
Trump the idea that because the number
isn't zero under any Administration that
it's this particular individual's fault
is absurd told in the sex slavery
unprecedented degree Mr secretary I want
to say to you right now your behavior is
disgraceful and the deaths the children
assaulted
they are at your feet and what about all
of the ones under Trump given that this
is a global issue it's not about
minimizing it's well it's very
capricious and arbitrary for Ted Cruz to
be indignant when Biden is president but
to never have said anything about the
exact same thing under Trump if you had
Integrity you would reside
and I will tell you the men and women if
Ted Cruz had Integrity he would have
resigned border patrol they've never had
a political leader undermine them they
secretary because you're willing to
willing to follow political orders this
is a crisis it's a disgrace and you
won't even admit this human tragedy is a
crisis
claiming one minute chairman time Mr
secretary would you like to respond to
any of those questions what the senator
said it was revolting I'm not going to
address it
I mean it's like why honestly why bother
why bother this is of no value or
meaning that is Ted Cruz desperate for
relevance
excited about the possibility of being
featured in compilations on Fox news of
what happened at the hearing that he is
just screaming and doing the sort of
Lindsey Graham routine that's the that's
the sort of routine Lindsey Graham the
Republican senator did during the
confirmation hearings of eventual
Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh
scream and act indignant and be furious
at people and it probably does make it
on to Fox News but we see through it
it's completely pathetic